I'll leave animal he looks more like a
model than a fighter but what do you
these like a Tyrannosaurus Rex with a
pretty face being undefeated doesn't
mean anything if you don't push yourself
go to the test the reason that I succeed
in life is because of my flaws need
motivation watch the top 10 with the
leave nation what's that believe nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from growing up in a rough neighborhood
to having his father abandon him when he
was born and having his single mother
died when he was 16 years old to
becoming the undisputed heavyweight
champion of the world and one of the
greatest boxers in history he's Mike
Tyson and he was my take on his top 10
Russo success vol 2 enjoy also if you
want to know what Mike Tyson other
leaders in the black community have to
say about excellence check out my 254
black excellent series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
mourning video for free to help you
build your confidence to link to join is
in the description below a good fight
just to be diligent and committed and
discipline doing what you hate to do but
do it like you love it
okay let's get off with rule number one
study success you at 20 Mohammed Ali at
20 who wins this fight there's no man
like him the Jeff isn't um everything
that we have he sees supersedes us and
even in our arrogance in our ego he's
fast but he really doesn't have any
great quality that you could really see
be surprised besides his agility not
afraid to let punches fly buzzing than
that he don't do a body punch in his
life he doesn't have good defense to
speed with his defense writings and
stuff say from a boxing perspective I
leave the animal he looks more like a
model than a fighter but what do you
he's like a Tyrannosaurus Rex with a
pretty face he's just mean and evil in
here here taking a deep water then drown
you he's very special
so is that it yeah yeah you beat him
well nobody found nobody beats Ali Wow
okay not right it's not it's not muscle
memory if concentration it's him doing
it pop-pop-pop-pop never stopping and
he's dead tired no I say you guys can't
beat that man hell no no way
rule number two know how to market
yourself how do you apply that to
business so what you've learned in
boxing the blessings being a champion
how that's interesting because ethanol
in business as in boxing you know how to
market yourself you have to know what's
gonna allow people to bring with the
Phillip deceits yeah and mine from my
situation came about I was the killer
I was the cycle tough guy about the
antihero and I'm the good guy wasn't a
bad guy just you know mean what I would
answer this is a dangerous sport boxing
and about making as much money you can
taking the lesser risk as possible yeah
well what do you feel yourself as did
this man all the way up yeah I know all
the way never think about I'm the champ
of the world never think about that
stuff because you can't only be able to
move forward how do you think that
sports and business can be similar or
what doesn't business on yeah same it's
too wait sports like me right yeah I'm
the show now I'm the business yeah it's
a nice show business well it was just a
show yeah rule number three master the
mind when I first found makeup we didn't
talk about punching and moving ahead we
all talked about the psychology of boxes
and the psychology of fear and he had
the psychology of fear down to a science
that was just it was all psychological
because Christopher Lee Boggs from of
90% psychological and timbers and
physical and I was pretty much a
psychological fighter even though I
would come across fear that's all the
part of the psychological game
intimidation being the tough guy and all
these how all these antics and it was
very successful towards me rule number
four challenge yourself all the good
fighters and I fighting each other you
know is it Dante Wilder
he's knocking out everybody but you know
he had a full array the guy in separate
guys they should fight before he fights
the clips go off what's this other guy
um the gentleman from Haiti what's his
name again
esta Ben you know he should fight some
contenders I'm not saying he's a bad
fighter he can't fight it looks like he
was going before the fighting started
this guy's gonna win that's not what
boxing Bell about something about being
pushed about being challenged about
challenging yourself you know you know
Muhammad Ali time we talked about Rocky
Marciano 49 I know Rocky Marciano got
his ass kick he fought for that oh he
fought the best fighter they beat his
ass he came back you know he didn't
either had the undefeated record by
osmosis
he fought for it he fought for it these
guys not fighting for it then defeated
records if you lost a fight look I like
the greatest fight ever lived
cost no one's going to be better than
having the great fight that we live in
he look so being undefeated doesn't mean
anything if you don't push yourself go
to the thethe rule number five ignore
the opinions of others what do you think
are the biggest misconceptions people
still have about you or have about you
know if you think about that no cuz
whatever someone thinks about me is not
my business yeah
did you come to learn that or its really
what it is yeah you know when I learnt
it someone explained it to me it's none
of my business talking about yeah
rule number six be driven by your flaws
you know when people tell me you're
great and you're the best you deserve
Oscar and I think of my demons I think
of my flaws you know because I'm the
reason that I succeed in life is because
of my flaws what's Lots
whatever they are they cause me to
ascend to high places in life because
that despised oh well number seven find
inner happiness I wanted to change my
life I didn't like the way I was living
my life I'm one of the different um I
just wanted to better a better way of
life you know I didn't want to be the
guy that had it all outside and had
nothing inside and I friend I realized
all this recovery and silver thing and
life in general is the inside job you
know you're looking finally if you're
looking for happiness from out here it's
gonna be disasters it from my
perspective maybe other people can get
it and I'm and I'm different I'm a
little scooter cuz I know something's
wrong up there I
real difficult situation receiving love
and stuff but you know sacrifice
rule number nine love just like there
are some people rooting for you there
are some people out there who think he's
gotten as many chances as I want to give
him what do you say to that I don't say
anything to them
I let them watch me ring you know and
only way that we could stop haters by
love and I thought like the wild thing
now is pretty much love I get to be one
of those people that have a lot of heat
so I know what I don't feel I'm not
angry at them I'm not mad at them and
understands just a disease is just the
illness because sometimes I'm we feel
comfort and hate you know we feel
comfort and I'm misery and so I
understand that world so I'm no one to
judge and rule number ten the last one
for a very special bonus clip is have
fun a Mike Tyson and we're on unboxing
at the moment we're gonna borrow unbox
strawberry shortcake this is very
difficult buck because as you know they
have strong strong adhesive tape around
here and so does I don't have no box
cutter I must do it very badly but in a
good mood
[Music]
Wow we have all these wives either be
very difficult to get it off the bar but
I'm gonna try to do this in
scientifically as possible this is this
beautiful please forgive me shortcake my
neighbor's a dancer in Vegas named
desire right
accidentally ripped a little bit of my
hair out and as I comb my hair it begins
to look better
nice and pretty and cute I really likes
to race you okay and so I like the fake
this is I might - on unboxing boxes now
I've got a special bonus clip from Mike
on how to work on being a good person
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life for business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what does inner
happiness look like for you number two
what flaw of yours can you be driven by
and number three whose opinions do you
need to ignore I was a street kid I
never knew I had the concept of what a
gold was we were to achieve something to
put in hard work in the debtor dedicate
your life to doing something and turn
them I meant I never understood that and
that's with my face both my life so just
achieving things and becoming the best
in the world on what I did the other
guys can also take that and put it in
other things in life know being a great
football player both so being a great
person because you only going to be a
great you know football play for small
in community life and either to t be a
person city that continuing working to
be the better person and proving itself
you know my mom this is really
interesting I'm telling you this stuff I
was a friend that God bless his soul
John Kennedy jr. right and I was getting
in trouble and I was in prison he came
to visit me and he was saying while it
was home he said I read about a lot of
great men but allowing all the great men
I read about weren't goodness so it's
also great to work on being a good
person you know also that's more
important than being a great man a great
football player and I think you're a lot
further to being a great athlete as well
if you want more Mike Tyson check out
the first top ten rules video made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there as we get
older we lose our hair we look at teeth
we lose mothers many times I quit boxing
this violin became a professional boxer